[Musica]
voi forse da ragazzi e ragazze
vi sarete trovati a pensare che quelli
che stanno qui sotto proprio dall'altra
parte della terra
camminano a testa in giù e a piedi in su
è capitato anche a me e vorrei
raccontare come è successo e come ne
sono venuto fuori
la storia incomincia il 4 gen
4 ottobre
1957 con lo sputnik che vuol dire
compagno di viaggio il primo satellite
artificiale
mandato sopra
la testa dell'umanità
dell'umanità stessa
era una palla di 60 cm
di metallo con quattro antenne stilo
dentro c'era solo un trasmettitore che
per tre giorni
emise un beep beep beep che fece
un'impressione terribile
perché voleva dire che si era entrati in
un nuovo mondo
a me onestamente io ero secondo
alimentare non fece e tanta impressione
ero molto più interessato al fatto che
la maestra
preso lo spunto per raccontarci che la
terra è tonda e quindi presi un
mappamondo
e se lo fece ben vedere vedete ragazzi
la terra è tonda poi siccome sapeva che
a me piaceva e piace ancora la geografia
mi disse vieni tu a far vedere i tuoi
compagni l'italia e la trovai subito
perché l'italia si può fare è un oggetto
che è una forma molto strana e
mentre perori davo il marchio al mondo
arriva il problema perché io passavo
tante ore sugli atlanti di mio fratello
che è più grande
per otranto è piatto e questo e tondo
allora ho detto alla maestra signora
maestra
ma quelli che stanno qui dall'altra
parte del mondo stanno a testa in giù
lei mi guardò e mi disse
ma no dai
sciocchino vai a posto e riprese a
spiegare
erano tempi in cui quello che diceva la
maestra non si poteva
discutere
e io rimasi molto pensieroso e come
vedete in questa foto
rimasi a lungo molto pensieroso perché
questa la foto della mia quinta
elementare
e il problema in cui ero incocciato è un
problema molto antico lo tirò fuori
probabilmente platone quindi
2500 anni prima di cristo e
venne risolto circa 1500 anni dopo
cristo come vedremo quindi un problema
che resta
4000 anni
sospeso e pensate che il cristianesimo
nel 2000 di anni e il mondo allora aveva
pensato diviso in fasce a nord ci siamo
noi che siamo egocentrici narcisisti c'è
l'europa c'è il medio oriente dove si
svolgono le storie della bibbia il mar
rosso mosè che lo divide in mezzo c'è
una fascia super calda che non si può
passare e sotto sotto se tanto mi dà
tanto doveva esserci una temperatura
tale per cui in questa terra incognita
conosciuta potevano esserci degli
abitanti
andammo avanti per
diciamo mille anni a dire che si poteva
esserci no poteva essere non esserci
guardate anche santi importanti come
sant'agostino erano contro l'esistenza
di abitanti di qui sotto che si chiamano
antipodi dall'altra parte dei miei piedi
finché nel 1493 vinse l'idea degli
antipodi
questa pagina di un libro meraviglioso
stupendo che si chiamano sono le
cronache di norimberga
sono 40 x 50 cm 336 pagine contiene
tutto lo scibile umano
dall'inizio fino al
1493 è uno dei quindi primi incunaboli
più grande e probabilmente mai stampato
e diciamo legalizza la presenza degli
antipodi però come spesso succede quando
non ci si vede in faccia si fanno le
fantasie un po strane quindi per esempio
ce n'era uno che faceva concorrenza
dumbo della disney
ce n'era uno con sei occhi uno con un
piede gigante e uno con i piedi
contrapposti è però era la conclusione
di una teoria
come sappiamo quando si è arrivato alla
conclusione di una teoria spesso succede
qualcosa che non ha niente a che fare
che scombina tutto e questo è
la ricerca per via di mare di nuovi
continenti va bene colombo non lo cito
neanche mille 492 ma poi viene scoperto
viene circumnavigare l'africa e poi
il messico troviamo e poi il brasile
avanti così fino al 1606 in cui
scopriamo l'australia
ma scopriamo anche cosa scopriamo che
dall'altra parte gli antipodi ci sono
sul serio
e sono
straordinariamente
diversi da noi è straordinariamente
simili a noi
e stanno come noi con la testa in su
perché la gravità che li tiene incollati
la stessa gravità che se io faccio
cadere questa palla ma benché il mondo
ma chiamiamo la palla la fa cadere al
suolo
è una questione insomma dei punti di
vista o quello che più
tecnicamente i sisi si chiamano sistema
di riferimento
che però nel nostro caso è molto
terrestre ultimo esempio
l'acqua sappiamo che va dove vuole e
sempre e sempre da sopra a sotto
d'accordo
se noi togliamo la gravità e andiamo in
un sistema di riferimento dove la vita
non c'è guardate cosa succede all'acqua
queste scott kelly un astronauta dei due
gemelli che con un collega abbiamo anche
conosciuto molto simpatico molto gentile
c'è pure regalato il suo libro e può
giocare a ping pong con quest'acqua che
resta dentro confinata in una pallina
incredibile quindi
disorienta questo disorienta il fatto
che nello spazio non ci sia né avanti né
indietro nella destra e di sinistra né
sopra né sotto
però anche se vogliamo
si dà l'idea della nostra dimensione
quel punto lino che vedete
scusate non volevo controllare quel
punto lino che vedete
è uno dei miliardi di pianeti nella
nostra galassia che girano attorno a
miliardi di stelle madri ed è presa la
immagina 6 miliardi di chilometri che
per noi sono tanti e con quello che
costa oggi a benzina ma
sono pochissimi in termini astronomici
d'accordo
e la terra
siamo tutti là
8 miliardi
tutti
tremendamente
diversi e tutti
eccezionalmente simili
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]